John got a fancy new chair
it's got lumbar support neck support
I don't care adjustable arms I don't
care this video is brought to you by
staples so what if I was selfish about
my chair
I said get a new chair I didn't expect
you to get a new chair it's okay man you
can you can try it out one of these
times maybe next video I'll let you take
a test I think if I go through the
history of our life I will find a way to
conclude that I should have that chair I
mean probably watch this joker gameplay
and fatalities Mortal Kombat 11 I'm
excited to check this out these Mortal
Kombat videos were made for reactions I
think and they were also made so that
way you too could give you a yellow
dollar bill sign until it's done getting
views let's do this god I gotta get
those ads down okay here we go yeah what
the hell
Oh haha I like how you don't yeah how
many gas tanks yeah a giant ass fish I
just want to go exploring now to make an
open world that no need to sense the
ground on vibrate to do with the
controller trying to make sure he gets
down yeah awesome awesome
oh god I've enjoyed this reaction more
if I had that chair you all sit on my
lap oh that's not necessary
Christopher Lambert hell yeah
that's my move I just kicked him in the
shins
I just want those poor wheelchair guy
Joker taking on a god it's possible so
when they do these do they make sure the
other guy loses a lot I don't know like
do they do them I hope I can eat easy
computer setting or something
I'll have this tribe around them it's
just like yep there's sort of things
that what we did
they won't stop I can't spell counter
with a
oh no mr. J get it down maniacally
gleeful I'd say sweet diggity sweet
things in life that was really good
maybe you should do let's place John in
your new chair oh this would be a
perfect chair for Let's Plays I mean it
would be comfortable to sit in for you
know at least five to ten hours back
support adjustable I can move these arms
up and down if I want what I don't even
know that yeah I can adjust the lumbar
support I can adjust the head support I
mean we don't even need to talk about
Mortal Kombat just just try the chamber
I want to try your stupid my chair is
classic it is chair I've had for years
that's that's what we do we bring a
little bit of classic and a little bit
of the future this is the chair of the
future um throw your white privilege
around me chair of the future so not a
whole bunch of new stuff that occurred
in here I mean you got that fatality at
least I haven't seen that one yet the
first one that was pretty sweet
and also like pouring the gasoline on
the ground that's an enough fire these
antics are great
I was hoping though that they would put
this gameplay together where he's
fighting Batman I'm hoping Batman will
be a DLC character I mean he's an
injustice you need to have you should
have a Batman villain a nomad
everybody's gonna want to have that
showdown I feel like that'd be so cool
especially like the hard are Zack Snyder
version of have Han that would be pretty
sweet to check out this combo this we
could replace the CG that's miss
from the Schneider cut with just clips
from Mortal Kombat God your arms look so
comfortable I can't get over it I'll
lower these lights so that they're like
Dobby love Joe mean you talk about
Mortal Kombat's
no or I know the background this is like
the mo even though like background was
very distracting yeah yeah because I was
sitting there going wow I would love to
explore this world ships in this giant
fish and then these like tribal people
in what looks like the Goblin mines from
Lord of the Rings yeah I like they're
getting more and more beautiful in the
backgrounds to which I feel like is
something that you just don't ever focus
the funnest part about this other than
just playing Mortal Kombat with a joker
skin it seems like you are getting yeah
that's sort of not Elseworlds but the
sensibility that you can't get
necessarily from the movies right now or
the comics that's just completely
gleeful violent disgusting that new
fatality especially I thought was very
fun I want them to put one of these
together their release in Mortal Kombat
11 you know whatever character right in
gameplay in fatalities and he just loses
the whole time yeah you don't even get
to see the vision gonna see any of that
yeah you see the fatalities done unto
him and when you watch these there are
times where it seems like who's
directing this video yeah you know what
I mean whoever is doing the marking or
like all right let ride and hit him a
few times now that way it feels like
it's a real fight house let him punch
him a few kicks in there like what's the
point though we just want to see the
gameplay and the fatalities so yeah I
think it'd be fun to completely troll us
and and do that to us well I mean we at
least god I wasn't expecting to see I
think that was that Johnny Cage Johnny
yeah he did like one of those did the
x-ray where it showed the Joker's bones
is like ribs breaking or something I
can't remember if it was Johnny cater
Raiden but you know I wasn't expecting
to see that level of damage you know
they put him in some peril well Joker
wanted that so that way he can suck his
own you know
yeah the Marilyn Manson thing yeah yeah
was breaking all your ribs part of your
plan oh yeah all right guys well Joker
came for fatalities I feel like this is
about as far as you can go they released
another one I am like
I thought all the new stuff will be here
but it was pretty familiar territory
from the last one
subscribe notification bells exist click
them so like buttons and dislike buttons
hit whatever one you want it's all
engagement at the end of the day ah
before we wrap this up I like to end
this with a page from the day shadow to
a man named Cal Dorian see penny coos
just the coolest name friend is a writer
from the four corners of America I asked
him what his resolutions water and he
said as for resolutions I suppose it's
something like strengthening myself
against unwarranted challenges I don't
know that's your first problem man you
got to really know you can't attract
something if it's you you're not clear
on what you want awry you got to have a
good vision identify the challenges I'd
say healthier but Who am I kidding I
ain't turning down food in this lifetime
dude you got to have that faith in
yourself that belief that you can turn
your life around if you have all this
negativity and doubt and cynicism
towards yourself you're never gonna
accomplish it publishers on the list
like every year for the past decade you
see will you I'm reading this you keep
putting yourself down Cal durian you
can't do that you know why is your
freakin name is Cal durian mm-hmm that
is the most badass that could be a
Mortal Kombat care you could rule over
Nations well then you know have people
fight in front of you all these
following sentences that are going
against your goals that are putting
yourself down even if it is in a
humorous sarcastic way they say sarcasm
is the beginning of death that's the
true fatality don't forget that man
mm-hmm
well seriousness you know just live your
life be in the moment and enjoy yourself
if these goals don't turn out this year
that's fine just keep moving on